(Risas)
Esto es solo lo negra que era mi mamá.
"Da a este chico el nombre más oscuro posible ¿Qué dice el libro?"
(Risas)
Rafiq es un nombre árabe, pero no somos árabes.
Mi madre solo quería que tuviera en el siglo XXI. problemas de embarque.
(Risas)
Ella previó el cambio de EE. UU. hacia el nativismo.
Ella fue una futurista negra.
(Risas)
Thurston es un nombre británico, pero no somos británicos.
Pero es un clamor para la institución económica multigeneracional
deshumanizante de la propiedad esclava estadounidense.
Además, Thurston queda bien para un nombre de Starbucks.
En serio, eso acelera el proceso.
(Risas)
Mi madre fue una mujer renacentista.
Arnita Lorraine Thurston
fue programadora de computadoras, extrabajadora doméstica
fue sobreviviente del asalto sexual,
artista y activista.
Ella me ha preparado para este mundo con lecciones de la historia de los negros
en arte marcial, en el cultivo urbano,
y luego me envió al colegio privado de Sidwell Friends en el 7º
donde los presidentes estadounidenses mandan a sus hijas
y donde ella me envió cuando yo era así.
(Risas)
Tuve dos deberes claves al ir a aquel colegio:
no pierdas tu negritud ni las gafas.
Esto cumple los dos.
(Risas)
Sidwell era un lugar genial para aprender arte y ciencias,
pero también el arte de vivir en medio de blancura
lo que me preparó luego para mi vida en Harvard,
para hacer consultoría corporativa,
o para mis trabajos en "The Daily Show" y The Onion.
Escribí muchas lecciones en mi autobiografía: "Como ser negro,"
el que si aún no han leído, les convierte en racistas, porque...
(Risas)
han tenido mucho tiempo para leerlo.
Pero EE. UU. insiste en recordarme
y enseñarme
lo que significa ser negro en EE. UU.
Es diciembre en 2018,
estaba con mi prometida en los suburbios en Wisconsin,
visitando a sus padres, ambos son blancos
lo que hace que ella también lo sea.
Así funciona. Yo no pongo las reglas.
(Risas)
Ella había bebido, así que yo conduje el auto de sus padres,
y la policía nos detuvo.
Tengo miedo.
Encendí luces intermitentes para indicar el cumplimiento.
Paro lentamente
bajo la farola más luminosa que podría encontrar
por si necesito testigos o imágenes televisivas.
Sacamos la identificación, los papeles de registro del auto,
Bajamos las ventanas y los sacamos.
Los manos están al volante,
eso todo sucede antes de que la policía salga de su vehículo.
Por eso estamos vivos.
Mientras esperábamos , pienso en posibles titulares:
"El polícia dispara a otro hombre negro desarmado".
Y no quiero que me pase lo mismo.
Tengo buenas noticias y es que nuestra agente de policía fue amable.
Ella nos avisó de que nuestras placas estaban caducadas.
Para todos padres blancos,
si tu hijo está vinculado a una persona
cuya piel se clasifica como Dawyne "The Rock" Johnson o aún más negro..
(Risas)
necesitas examinar el auto, renovar los papeles antes de cada visita.
Es por cortesía.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Yo tuve suerte.
Tuve un profesional en la aplicación de la ley.
Sobreviví a algo que no debería requerir supervivencia.
Y pienso en esta serie de cuentos
"El policía dispara a otro hombre negro desarmado".
y la época cuando aquellos cuentos estaban en todos lugares.
Me gustaría pasear por mis memoria
y entonces veo una foto para un anuncio de un bebé,
un anuncio para un producto
que ayer había compartido con un amigo.
Me gustaría ver un video de un policía apuntando con un arma otra persona
que se pareciera a mí.
Y me gustaría leer un artículo sobre
cómo la generación del milenio sustituye el sexo por una tostada de aguacate
(Risas)
Era un tiempo de confusión.
Esas historias siguen apareciendo
pero en 2018 esas historias cambiaron por otras como:
"Una mujer blanca llama a la policía porque una mujer negra espera un Uber"
Era Brooklyn Becky.
"Otra mujer blanca llama a la policía
porque una niña negra de 8 años vende agua".
Ella era Permit Patty.
Y "Otra mujer llama a la policía
porque una familia negra hace una barbacoa en un lago de Oakland".
Ahora se conoce con la triste fama de Becky Barbacoa.
Y compito contra esas historias sobre la vida de los negros
mientras realmente los negros están progresando.
Solíamos descubrir asesinatos extrajudiciales de la policía,
ahora recibimos los videos de la gente llamando 911
Estamos moviéndonos contracorriente
acercándonos al problema y a la solución
Entonces, empezé a coleccionar
tantas historias como pude encontrar.
Creé una base de datos que sigue creaciendo
en el sitio web: baratunde.com/livingwhileblack
En busca de entendimiento, entendí
que estaba diagramando oraciones para comprender los titulares.
Quería dar las gracias a mi maestra de inglés en Sidwell, Erica Berry
y a todos los maestros de inglés.
Nos han dado los instrumentos para luchar para nuestra libertad.
Lo que he encontrado es un proceso para descomponer el titular
y entender los niveles coherentes
de cada uno:
Un sujeto hace una acción contra un objetivo participado en actividades
entonces "una mujer blanca llama a la policía por una chica negra"
es el mismo que "un hombre blanco llama a la policía porque una mujer negra
ha usado la piscina de los vecinos" y "una mujer llama a la policía
porque un legislador negro hace campaña en su área".
Son iguales.
Diagramar las oraciones me permitió diagramar la supremacía de la blancura
lo que permite a tales oraciones ser correctas.
Voy a parar un poco para explicar las definiciones,
"la supremacía de la blancura".
No estoy hablando de nazis
o activistas blancos y poderosos,
Sin duda, no digo que todos los blancos sean racistas.
A lo que me refiero es que
el sistema de beneficios estructurales que favorece más a los blancos
en espacios sociales, económicos y políticos.
Este es lo que Bryan Stevenson en "the Equal Justice Initiative"
llama la narrativa de la diferencia racial,
el cuento que nos explicamos para justificar la esclavitud y Jim Crow,
la encarcelación en masa, etc.
Entonces, cuando entendí este modelo repetitivo,
me enfadé,
pero esto me animó al mismo tiempo
para crear un juego,
un juego de palabras que me permite transformar esta exposición traumática
en una experiencia sanadora.
Hablaré sobre el juego.
El primero nivel es del ejercitarse, y necesito su participación.
Nuestro objetivo: es determinar si esto es real o falso.
¿Esto pasó o no?
Por ejemplo:
"Un bibliotecario de la Universidad Católica de Derecho llama a la policía
porque un estudiante estaba discutidor.
¡Aplaudan si creen que esto es real!
(Aplausos)
¡Aplaudan si creen que esto es falso!
Los que creen que es real tienen razón, por desgracia,
y la información, ser discutidor
en la biblioteca de Derecho
es el lugar adecuado para hacerlo.
(Risas)
Este estudiante debería ser profesor.
El nivel de formación se completa y continuamos con los niveles reales.
Nivel uno, nuestro objetivo es simple:
invertimos los roles.
Significa "Una mujer llama a la policía a causa de un legislador negro"
se convierte en "Un legislador negro llama a la policía a causa de una mujer".
Significa "Un hombre blanco llama a la policía
porque una negra utiliza la piscina de los vecinos
se convierte en "una negra llama a la policía a causa de un blanco".
¿Cómo quieres revertir las manzanas racistas?
Eso es; el nivel uno es completo
Continuamos con el nivel dos,
donde el objetivo es aumentar la credibilidad del cambio.
Hagámoslo, una mujer negra llama a la policía porque un blanco usa la piscina
no es lo suficiente absurdo,
pero ¿qué pasaría si el hombre tocara su pelo sin preguntarla?
o ¿si él preparase la leche con avena montando en un monociclo?
o ¿si quizá hablase de los demás en una reunión?
(Risas)
¿Hemos estado allí, correcto?
En serio, todos hemos estado allí
Eso es, nivel dos completo.
Eso viene con aviso:
Simplemente invertir la corriente de injusticia no es justo.
Es una venganza que no es nuestra misión.
Es un juego diferente, ahora continuamos al nivel tres,
que es cambiar la acción, conocida como
"Llamar a la policía no es tu única opción.
¿Qué les pasa, gente?"
(Aplauso)
Necesito hacer una pausa para recordar la estructura.
Un sujeto hace una acción contra un objetivo participado en una actividad
"Una blanca llama a la policía porque un inversor inmobiliario negro
inspecciona su propiedad"
"Un supermercado llama a la policía porque una blanca
dona comida a la gente sin hogar."
"Un club llama a la policía dos veces porque una negra juega demasiado lento".
En todos casos el sujeto es siempre blanco,
el objetivo es negro,
y las actividades son cualquier cosa,
sentarse en Starbucks,
utilizar el tipo incorrecto del barbacoa,
echarse la siesta,
andar "nervioso" de camino al trabajo,
lo que llamo "andar hasta el trabajo"
(Risas)
y, mi favorito,
hacer que su perro deje de chupar el perro de ella,
lo que es una situación seria para el perro de policía
no para la policía real.
Todas esas actividades suman en la vida.
Nuestra existencia se entiende como un delito.
Pero es obligatorio decir en mi presentación
que no todo va sobre el racismo.
El delito es una cosa que debería ser reportado,
pero pregúntense ¿Necesitamos hombres armados para solucionar esto?
Porque para mí, cuando ellos aparecen,
es diferente.
Conocemos que la policía
usa la fuerza contra los negros más que contra los blancos,
y aprendemos que el 911 es la manera para hacerlo.
Gracias a la investigación preliminar del "Center for olicing Equity"
sabemos que en unas ciudades
la mayoría de las interacciones entre la policía y los ciudadanos
es a través de las llamadas al 911,
no por detenciones de la policía.
La mayoría de actos violentos y de fuerza de la policía contra los ciudadanos
son las repuestas a aquellas llamadas.
Además, cuando aquellos agentes responden a las llamadas usando la fuerza,
aumenta en lugares
donde el porcentaje de blancos
ha aumentado también,
lo conocido por gentrificación,
por monociclos y por la leche de avena,
y cuando Becky Barbacoa se siente en peligro,
ella se convierte en un peligro para el barrio,
que me obliga a mí y a otras personas como yo
a ser nosotros mismos agentes de policía.
Nos tranquilizamos, vamos con pies de plomo.
Quizás vayamos al lado de la carretera
allá bajo la luz que podemos encontrar
para que el asesino
quizá sea detectado por la cámara.
Y lo hacemos porque vivimos en un sistema
en el cual los blancos diariamente pueden llamar a las autoridades
para asegurarse de que todo va bien para ellos.
(Aplausos)
El vendedor del mercado no solo llamó
a la policía porque una negra donaba comida a la gente sin hogar.
Ellos ordenaron muchos hombres armados contra ella.
Básicamente pidieron un ataque con drones.
Eso es incomodidad armada,
y eso no es nuevo.
Desde 1877 hasta 1950,
al menos se documentaron 4400 linchamientos raciales
de negros EE. UU.
Tuvieron titulares también.
"La revolucionaria T.A Allen fue linchado en Hernando, Mississippi
por organizar aparceros locales".
"Oliver Moore fue linchado en Edgecomb County, Carolina del Norte
por asustar a una chica blanca.
Nathan Bird fue linchado cerca Luling, Texas
por rechazar que su hijo fuera a una banda.
Necesitamos cambiar la acción,
de un linchamiento
o de llamar a la policía.
Y ahora que he disminuido la distancia entre ambas,
volvamos al juego, a la misión.
Nuestro objetivo en el nivel tres es cambiar la acción.
Entonces, ¿Qué pasa si, en vez de
llamar a la policía porque una negra dona comida
a gente sin hogar, que el supermercado dé las gracias?
Dar las gracias es más barato que llamar a la policía.
(Aplauso)
O, en vez de,
dar la comida que ellos han perdido por ella
para donarla en algo bueno para todos.
O si la mujer blanca que llamó a la policía a causa de una niña negra de 8,
comprara agua de la chica
para apoyarla?
¿Y si la mujer blanca que llamó a la policía debido a un inversor inmobiliario,
pudiéramos ser mejores, los policías también lo piensan,
si ella lo ignorase y se ocupara de sus propios asuntos?
(Risas)
Atender los asuntos propios es una opción excelente.
Háganlo más a menudo.
El nivel tres es completo, pero hay un nivel más y final,
donde el objetivo es la inclusión.
Hemos visto tales titulares:
"Un hombre poderoso se masturba delante de mujeres jovenes
que visitan su oficina"
¡Qué estupidez de un hombre poderoso!
Puede hacer muchas otras cosas.
(Risas)
Como, por ejemplo, "escucha a",
"asesora a"
"inspirado por, crea una empresa, todos somos ricos ahora".
(Risas)
Quiero vivir en ese mundo donde todos son ricos,
pero porque él no eligió bien, todos estamos en un mundo peor.
No debería pasar así.
La palabra de juego me recordó la supremacía de la blancura,
como ser misógino,
como todos abusos sistemáticos del poder.
La estructura los hace sistemáticos.
Pido a las personas aquí
que vean la estructura,
donde está el poder,
aunque es más importante ver la humanidad
de todos quienes hacen los objetivos según esta estructura.
Estoy aquí porque fui amado, protegido y tuve suerte
porque estuve en los colegios adecuados, por ser semifamoso, casi siempre feliz
meditando dos veces al día,
y todavía,
tengo miedo,
porque estoy seguro de que si alguien me considera como un peligro
puede poner en peligro mi vida,
estoy cansado.
Estoy cansado por asumir
esta responsabilidad de los miedos de los demás,
la mayoría de nosotros está cansados
y no lo deberíamos estar,
porque podemos cambiar esto,
podemos cambiar la acción que cambia la historia,
que cambia el sistema
que permite que sucedan estas historias.
Los sistemas son historias colectivas que todos aceptamos.
Cuando las cambiamos,
escribimos una realidad mejor para ser un parte de ella.
Nos pido
usar nuestro poder para elegir.
Pido a todos nosotros subir de nivel.
Gracias.
Soy Baratunde Rafiq Thurston.
(Aplauso)